Welcome back.
Well, I've been requested
to do several problems by
our friend [? Akosh. ?]
So I thought I would
keep doing them.
I'm skipping around
a little bit.
Because I think if I did
all of them, it would just
generate too many videos.
But I encourage all of you all
to let me know if you feel that
there's something that
I might have missed.
But anyway, I'm just going
through some of the
problems he gave.
So this one-- and I actually
almost find it funny, because
they use such formal language
for something that's actually
a pretty intuitive concept.
Well they say, use the
monotonicity theorem to find
where the given function is
increasing, and when
it is decreasing.
Monotonicity theorem.
It make sound very serious.
Well all the monotonicity
theorem-- at least if I'm
remembering things properly--
all it says is when the
derivative is positive, when f
prime of x is greater than 0,
your function is increasing.
And when the derivative is
negative, your function
is decreasing.
And why am I kind of
disparaging of this?
Well what's the derivative?
The derivative is the slope.
And you learned in Algebra
1, that if the slope is
positive, the graph of
the line is increasing.
And if the slope is
negative, the graph of
the line is decreasing.
And the only thing that's
different now is that this
function isn't necessarily
a line, it's a function.
So it could be a curve.
But having a positive slope
means that the value of the
function is increasing.
For every change it x, there's
a positive change in y.
And similarly, a negative slope
says that for every change in
x, no matter how small, there's
a negative change in y.
So there's nothing fancy here.
But let's see, they
gave some examples.
So they want us to use this
theorem to find where the
given function is increasing,
and when it is decreasing.
So the first function
they give is f of x is
equal to 3x plus 3.
What's the derivative of this?
f prime of x is equal to 3.
For any value of x
this is a positive.
Right?
F prime of x is positive
for all values of x.
So this thing, using the
monotonicity theorem
is positive.
Sorry, it's increasing
for all values of x.
And you could have done
that in the 9th grade.
How?
Well you would have said, this
is the slope y-intercept.
The slope is 3.
So this is an
increasing function.
The function will look
something like this.
The y-intercept is 3.
And the slope is 3.
So this function looks
something like that.
And so it's increasing over
from minus infinite to positive
infinite over that interval,
if you wanted to be fancy.
But this is really just a lot
of fancy terminology to talk
about, I think, something
fairly straightforward.
Anyway, the next one looks a
little bit more interesting.
H of z is equal to z to the
fourth over 4, minus-- and I
hope I'm reading this right--
4 z to the third over 6.
So let's see if we can figure
out when this is increasing,
and when this is decreasing,
when the function is
increasing or decreasing.
So what's the
derivative of this?
H prime of z is equal to 4.
This will cancel out.
So it's z to the third,
4z to the third over 4.
So it's z to the third minus 3
times 4 is 12z squared over 6.
So it's 2 2z squared.
So we just have to figure out
when is this function greater
than 0, and when is this
function less than 0.
And to figure this out, we
really just have to break out
our algebra toolkit to figure
out well one, when does
this function equal 0?
So let's set z-cubed minus
2z squared is equal to 0.
We could factor
out a z-squared.
And then we have z
minus 2 is equal to 0.
So we know that either
z-squared is equal to 0, or
z minus 2 is equal to 0.
So the points at which the
derivative is 0, so H prime
of 0 is equal to 0,
and H prime of 2.
And that's just our Algebra 2.
So H prime of 2 is equal to 0.
And so we just have to figure
out what happens in the
interval maybe when we're
below 0, between 0 and
2, and then above 2.
So what is the derivative?
So when we're below 0,
let's just take a point.
Let's say H prime of negative
1 is equal to what?
That is equal to negative 1 to
the third is negative 1, minus
2 times negative 1 squared.
Well negative 1 squared
is just positive 1.
So it's minus 2.
So it equals minus 3.
OK, let's take a point
in between these two.
Well 1 is in between them.
So let's just take H prime
of 1 is equal to 1 minus 2.
Lets make sure I'm
doing that right.
Because it's 1 squared.
So it equals negative
1, H prime of 1.
And then what happens when we
go of z values greater than 2.
So let's try 3.
H prime of 3 is equal to what?
H prime of 3 is equal to 27--
what's minus 2 times 9.
It's equal to 9,
right, 18, right.
So it's positive.
So, what do we know?
We know that in all fairness,
this is kind of an
interesting problem.
Because the derivative
is negative.
So if we were to draw the
derivative of this, what are
the interesting points?
It's 0.
So that's the x-axis.
That's 0.
And then we had 2.
And I'm going to draw
the derivative.
I'm not drawing the
actual function.
Because the monotonicity
theorem, we care about
whether the derivative
is positive or negative.
So what this tells us is
that the derivative, it
was a negative when we're
to left of 0, right?
Because we just
took a test point.
Because we know it's 0 here.
But then what happened?
It's not like it
got positive then.
It went back negative
again when we tried to
derivative it once.
It probably does
something like this.
Now what would it be?
Then it goes up at 2 where
it's greater than 0.
Right.
I was confusing
myself for a second.
Right.
So the derivative, it starts.
But it never goes
above right there.
So the derivative probably
has a bit of a maximum
point there or something.
This is the
derivative, remember.
That's why I was
confusing myself.
And then it probably
flips around, and then
goes above there.
But from the monotonicity
theorem, what do we care about?
We care about the intervals
where the derivative
is positive, and the
derivative is negative.
So if the derivative is
positive for all of
these values, for z
is greater than 2.
So we could say, using the
monotonicity theorem, this
function is increasing
when z is greater than 2.
So let me write that.
And then we can say that the
function is decreasing.
We could say flat or
decreasing, right?
Because the slope of the
function is 0 right here.
And remember this is the
graph of the derivative.
So we could say flat
or decreasing when
z is less than 2.
You normally do consider flat,
monotonic in one direction.
So you could say monotonic
increasing would still
include something that
kind of flattens out.
Well anyway, I'm
pushing ten minutes.
And I don't think I have time
for the next problem, which I
might do in the next video.
But hopefully you found
that a little bit helpful,
and not too confusing.
I will see you in
the next video.